[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDY: So we're going
to start by having
Brady Robinson from Access Fund
give a few words introduce him.
And then, hopefully,
in the meantime,
we'll get both screens
up and running.
So thanks, Brady.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY ROBINSON:
I'm Brady Robinson,
I'm the executive director
of the Access Fund.
We're the national
organization that
keeps climbing areas open and
conserved in the United States.
Tommy's a former board
member, and lucky enough
to get to introduce him today.
I just wanted to tell you a
little bit about what we do.
We've got staff all
around the country.
We've got someone in
Sonora, California.
Anybody know where that is?
Reasonably?
Yeah.
Near Jailhouse-- Gold
Wall-- anybody climb there?
Is everybody here a climber?
Most-- more-- more--
pretty much?
OK.
I've just got to gauge
the audience, here.
All right.
Good.
Yeah, so we're based in Boulder.
We've got staff
around the country.
And the only way we can
have a national reach
and be relevant nationally,
is with our affiliate
organizations.
We have over 100
affiliate organizations.
One of, frankly, our most well
organized and most effective
is the Bay Area
Climbers Coalition.
Ally, great job setting
everything up here.
So we work in partnership
with local groups.
We're the national,
they're the local.
And a few of the things
that we've been able to
do here, recently--
we've-- so Castle Rock
State Park, for a long time,
had a bolting ban.
Basically, you couldn't
even replace bolts.
We worked in partnership with
Bay Area Climber's Coalition
to try to reverse that, so that
when we are clipping things
in the outdoors,
they're hopefully safe,
and we can depend
our lives on it.
We finally got
permission to do that.
And this very next
weekend, Ally, you all
are doing a rebolting
effort out there.
They have enough
volunteers for that.
They could use a little more
coin for the hardware, however.
And so if you would like to make
a donation to the local group,
you can do that with your
badge, and Google will match it.
You can also support
the Access Fund,
as a national organization.
We get the majority of our
funding for our 24 staff
through individual donations
from people just like you.
Since 2011, Google
employees and the company,
through gift matching,
have given us over $38,000.
So if you're a part of that, I
want to thank you, personally,
for supporting
climbing and this--
utilizing this generous gift
matching that Google offers up.
We've also-- we're
working on the Gold Wall.
We got Jailhouse
open, a while back.
Anybody-- any Jailhouse
aficionados here?
OK.
Not as many.
That's cool.
Something to aspire
to-- it's kind of hard.
We're working on the Yosemite
Climbing Management Plan--
who's been to Yosemite, here?
And climbed Yosemite?
El Cap?
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
More things to aspire to.
We're also doing a stewardship--
Access Fund is doing
a stewardship training
in Yosemite this very weekend.
So we're taking local climbing
volunteers and land managers
for four days and
then teaching them,
like-- what is this
climbing thing?
How do you manage it?
How do you take--
how do you take care
of these places?
One of the issues that we're
dealing with in our community
now is that climbing
gyms are sprouting
up all over the
nation and more people
are coming into the sport.
And so, on the one hand,
that's great-- we're
becoming more of a
political constituency,
climbers voices actually matter.
We just got back
from Washington DC--
Tommy and I were there
advocating for public lands
and Bears Ears--
the voice of the climbers.
Honestly, unthinkable even
maybe eight years ago,
that climbers would be a
political constituency.
We are-- from my perspective,
that's good news.
The flip side of
that is-- there's
more of us in the outdoors.
And so increasingly, certainly
with Bay Area Climbers
Coalition and the Access Fund--
increasingly, we're
working on not just making
sure that we have
access to these places,
but they're not getting trashed
as a function of our use.
So again, we're doing
a lot in the area.
I won't go more
into that, really,
but thank you for your
generosity in that.
We are doing a--
we're doing our stand up
for public lands event--
these little cards are
available over there--
in Oakland, September ninth.
He's not confirmed yet,
but I think Jimmy Chin's
going to be the key note.
So if you're friends
with him on social media,
give him a little nudge.
[LAUGHTER]
But hopefully he's
going to confirm.
And so, yeah-- so
again, that's great.
Oh, and our partnership
with Google--
so Sandy is incredible.
She was the force behind
the Street View Mapping
of the Nose, and has
done a really great job,
from my perspective, of
identifying other cool things
to do in the climbing world.
And we did a Street View Mapping
of the Homestead in Arizona.
So if you're at your
desk, and you've
got a little time to kill,
try to find the Street
View of the Homestead.
We-- have you all seen the
trekker that you guys have--
like weigh 55 pounds?
We hiked through one
of our climbing areas
and mapped it out for you,
so you can check that out.
We're also-- Google
is supporting us
in an inventory and
a mapping project
at Red Rocks, outside of Nevada.
So one of the greatest
climbing areas in the country.
Your company is supporting
us in walking through there
and doing an inventory,
so we can figure out
where the trails are, and which
ones need to be worked on.
So we have a great partnership
with your company, as well.
And I'm personally
just kind of a fan.
So finally, though--
Tommy.
So I'll keep this fairly short.
Tommy is one of the greatest
climbers of our generation,
hands down.
He's a great guy.
He served on our
board for six years
when he had a lot of
other things to do.
And I think the one
thing I would just say,
before I turn it
over to Tommy is--
it's really hard
for us to fathom
the amount of time
and dedication
it took for him to do the
Dawn Wall with a completely
uncertain outcome.
So my little tiny
insight into that--
so I was fortunate
enough to climb
the Nose of El Capitan in 2012.
And I climbed it
with two other guys.
We climbed it in a day.
We got to the top.
We were exhausted.
We were beat down.
We were walking down the
east ledge's descent,
rappelling down,
kind of in a stupor,
and there's a head lamp at
the bottom of the ropes.
It's like 10:30 at
night, maybe 11.
I can't remember
what time it was.
And it looked like
somebody was going
in the wrong
direction-- coming up
the ropes we were going down.
Who the heck would
be by themselves,
humping a huge load, in
the middle of the night?
Tommy Caldwell.
That is the sort of dedication
it took to not only find
that there was a possible
route on that part of El Cap,
but then, ultimately, rehearse
the moves over many years
and finally ascend the thing.
It's incredible the
amount of dedication
and just the number
of hours he put in,
where nobody was looking,
there were no cameras,
and it was just what he did.
So Tommy, it's my
pleasure to introduce you.
Come on up and--
Tommy Caldwell--
[APPLAUSE]
TOMMY CALDWELL:
Yeah, I got this one.
Hello.
Awesome.
This is actually my second
time coming to Google
to present a show.
We came to present the
Street View one other time.
And it was pretty
surprising to me
when I came before-- it was
like this roomful of climbers.
I thought I'd come
speak to a bunch of tech
nerds or something, and it turns
out it's climber nerds instead.
Yeah, it felt like I was
in a room of friends.
It's been pretty
extraordinary to me,
to see climbing go
where it's gone.
I mean, I felt like I spent
the majority of my life
in this close-knit
community, where
it was just a bunch of climbers
and I knew basically everybody.
But in the last few years, or
10 years or so, it's expanded
and climbing is having this
reach that it never has before.
I mean, just the
fact that there's
is this many climbers
at Google, and I'm
coming to Google to speak these
days, and going to Capitol Hill
and lobbying--
we have a voice,
and, really, Google's
been a big part of that.
And so I just want
to thank you guys.
Thanks, Sandy.
Yeah-- helping to spread the
great word because I feel
like climbing has the
power to transform lives,
and it's such a great activity.
So my presentation today--
I was-- I'm in the
midst of a book tour--
crazy book tour--
25 stops or something
in three weeks.
And Sandy managed,
like she always does,
convince us to squeeze
one more in, here, today,
which is really fun.
Yeah so this book is--
it's pretty deep.
I think that when people
start reading it, they'll--
you know, that's
been the major input,
like, I was really vulnerable.
And I've got to admit when I--
when I sat down and I knew
I wanted to write something,
I would try to transcend the--
you know, kind of the typical
climbing book or even sports
memoir world, and I knew
I had to go really deep.
I tried to think as little
about what other people would
think of that.
I just knew I
needed to make it as
close to my heart as possible.
And then, on publication
day, last week,
I was walking to my first event
feeling slightly unnerved,
a little vulnerable.
I was like, I'm about to
expose the depths of my soul
to the entire world.
And I was walking
down the street
in New York City, on my way
to my first event, and--
hold on one second.
And I came across
this sign, right here.
Crossing the street--
high four and a half.
New York City giving
me a little nudge--
everything is going
to be just fine.
As this book is
revealed to the world,
I've had quite a few people
in the literary world come up
to and be like--
a memoir at age 38?
Like-- aren't you
supposed to be at least 70
or something to write
something like that?
And the truth is-- maybe.
Maybe you should wait that long.
But there's a reason that I
decided to write this book now,
and it really comes
down to this moment
that Brady mentioned
on the Dawn wall.
This is January 14, 2015.
And this was a crazy day in
my life, for a lot of reasons.
First of all, it
was something that I
had worked for really for
seven years, specifically
on this route.
But in a way, I felt like
it was the culmination
of like my entire life.
I started climbing
when I was three,
and this kind of
took all the skills
that I had accumulated to
come to this one moment
that I really wasn't sure
was ever going to happen.
I worked on this thing
for a lot of years,
and I totally gave up
on several occasions,
and something would
always bring me back.
And it was just this
incredible journey.
And this moment, here, was
the realization of that,
so it was really emotional.
The other reason it
was crazy, though,
is because, like I said,
I felt like I've always
lived in this little
close-knit climbing community.
And I've been a
professional climber,
so climbers have followed
along in this way,
but topping out
on this day was--
something happened in the media.
About three years before
this, my climbing partner,
Kevin Jorgenson, had
started using social media
to tell people about what
we're doing up on the wall--
started posting updates
on this climb to Twitter.
And at first, I was
kind of a curmudgeon.
I was like, no
climbing, it's soulful.
It's just about me and your
buddy in the mountains,
and we shouldn't really let
anybody into this world.
But we came down from
this first climb--
or this year that he was posting
Twitter updates, and every day,
people would come up
to me and be like--
man, when are you going back?
That was the most
inspiring thing ever.
You know, the highlight
of my day at work
was watching-- you
know, going on Twitter
and figuring out what
you guys were doing.
And so I started to change
my view on it a little bit.
I started to feel like
if we weren't sharing,
it was almost like
being selfish.
We were keeping this
experience to ourselves.
So I followed suit.
I started going on
Facebook and Instagram,
and doing the same thing
in the subsequent years.
And for a while, the climbing
community followed along.
Then, most people gave up on us
because they're like-- they're
never going to do that thing.
Nobody had actually
worked on a route
for that many years in a row.
But then, in 2014,
or the end of 2014,
beginning of 2015, as it seemed
like it might actually happen,
the climbers got super stoked.
And then that energy
started to bleed
outside of the climbing world.
A gentleman by the name of
John Branch from "the New York
Times" wrote an article
for "the New York Times".
It got picked for the
cover of the newspaper
and there was a lot of interest.
And then it just kind
of spread from there.
The Times decided to run
articles on the cover
for like five consecutive
days, and there were something
like 13 billion media--
media impressions.
And so we were up
there on the wall,
in our little
community of climbers,
and we had a filmmaker up there.
And we were looking
down at El Cap meadow
and seeing all these trucks show
up, and it was kind of nuts.
So I hucked my
phone off the wall.
I was like-- we've got to stay
in the midst of this climbing
experience, but when we
topped out on this day,
you couldn't ignore it anymore.
I had climbed El Cap
65 times by this point,
and nobody had ever
greeted me on top.
And this was the
middle of January
and like 80 people showed up on
the top of El Cap with cameras.
The president called--
President Obama
called to congratulate us.
There was this really crazy
phenomenon over the next days,
where I would walking down
the streets in Yosemite,
or I went to New York
pretty quickly after this,
and like, old
ladies would come up
to me with tears in their eyes.
And they're like-- that was
the most inspiring thing ever.
And I was thinking to myself,
like-- old ladies are just
not the demographic
I thought would be
inspired by this kind of thing.
This is so strange.
But one thing this did
is it kind of clued me
into the power of storytelling.
I think people think that social
media is this quick tip format,
but I actually think when
it's done most effectively,
it's a pretty long--
long format way to
still tell stories.
You can actually follow
somebody's life indefinitely.
And these news stories
were cool, in some ways.
And sort of the most
reputable news sources did--
did the story justice, I
felt like-- like the New York
Times and NPR.
But the vast majority
just took climbing
and they sensationalize--
sensationalized it.
They had all the facts wrong.
They said we were
climbing without ropes.
And it like-- a little
bit of my heart broke.
I was like, oh, this sport
that I am so endeared to,
and is actually being
spread to the world.
It's great it's being
spread in the world,
but it's like-- they're
not getting it quite right.
And so I started to feel like
I needed to write a book.
And so yeah-- it was funny.
I came down from
the Dawn Wall, I
had all these
emails in my inbox,
and I had kind of decided
that I wanted to write a book.
And so I started going
through the emails,
and there was a
few literary agents
and publishing companies.
And so I emailed
them back, and I
decided to go to New York City.
And on the plane,
I was like, oh, I'm
going to meet with
literary agents,
but I have, really, no
idea what I'm going to say
or how to write a book.
So I just quickly
started typing,
and I like typed my
whole life story out
on the airplane on the
way to New York City.
And then I emailed it off
that night to the people
I was meeting the next morning.
And then I met-- went
and met with everybody,
and most of them were like--
yeah, you should probably
get a ghost writer.
[LAUGHTER]
Most athletes don't actually
write their own memoirs.
But there was this one
guy, David Laribel,
who believed in my story,
for whatever reason.
And he said, I
think you can write.
I think you have potential here.
And he sort of
started advising me,
so that's the guy I picked
as my literary agent.
He said, you should write
a 50 page book proposal
and show them what
you can actually do.
And so I spent two months
working on this book proposal.
And, you know, it was kind
of-- it was this thing where--
I didn't really know
how to write a book,
but I know how to
climb mountains,
so I just started to approach
it like I do climbing mountains.
First, I did some research.
And I'm really lucky to live in
this community of good authors.
I called up Jon Krakauer,
who-- you guys have probably
heard of him, he's a bit
of a friend of mine--
and got some information
from him, and Jim Collins,
and they expressed
a lot of confidence
in me, which was huge.
And they also just kind of
gave me some business advice.
But then, really, the
most important thing
when you're writing
a book, or when
you're climbing a
mountain, actually,
is to get a good partner.
So I called my next door
neighbor-- this guy,
right here, Kelly Cordes,
and I decided that he would--
we decided together that we
were going to kind of embark
on this journey together.
And the working process was--
I would sit down and
write the chapters,
and try and make them
as good as I could.
And then he would take
his more literary mind
and help me elevate them.
And so I think the whole
ghostwriting thing didn't
really appeal to me because as
a climber, I was like-- well,
you don't hire somebody to
climb a mountain for you,
but you do find a good partner.
And so I think it
worked pretty well.
I hope people will
like the book.
It's
Kind of a testament that
if you get the right people
on the bus with you and
you work really hard,
you can venture
into realms that you
have no idea what it's like.
And, climbers do
this all the time.
So I sat down and
I started writing.
And you would think
after the Dawn Wall,
I would have written
about the Dawn Wall,
but I felt moved to write
about a very different moment
in my life.
It was 15 years earlier.
And it was this moment that
was so intense that I had never
really let myself go
back there, I think.
Climbers tend to
focus very intensely
on the things that will help
them get their jobs done--
or really, people that really
excel in any world do this,
I suppose.
And for me, writing was
very different than that.
Instead of focusing
intensely, I felt
like I had to take those
binoculars off and see
everything.
And so I went back to this
moment when I was 21 years old.
This first excerpt to read
is my first big international
climbing expedition to the the
of Kyrgyzstan, in Central Asia.
And this-- the other
characters in this excerpt
are Jason Singer
and John Dickey.
They were the male
members of the expedition.
Beth Rodden was my
girlfriend at the time.
And then Su and Abdul are
members of the Islamic Movement
of Uzbekistan.
We, as relatively naive,
young, American climbers
had gone into this
mountain region
figuring that the
mountains are a safe place.
In this part of the world,
that wasn't the case in 2001.
There was kind of
an opium trade trail
that appeared through
the mountains.
And the Islamic
Movement of Uzbekistan
moved over these really high
mountain passes, when the snow
melted, from one side of us.
And then the Kyrgyz military
came from the other side,
and we were at that
point of collision.
We got taken hostage
for six days in a war.
We had to abandon everything
that we had with our captors--
no warm clothes, no
food, on the verge
of hypothermia for six days,
where we just got closer
and closer to death, frankly.
And by the end, it was
getting pretty real.
So this excerpt is
this moment that I
felt moved to write about.
So this was-- these were
the very first words
I wrote in this book.
"Starvation is a funny thing.
You feel it first in your
stomach, a nauseating pain,
low in your gut.
Your breathing becomes
labored and your body slows.
Your mind goes next.
Indifference takes over.
Emotions dull.
But after several days, the
pain in my stomach went away.
I still don't know how it
happened or where it came from,
but as everyone else grew
weaker, I felt stronger.
I noticed my night
vision improving.
Lines became crisp.
By the time the sun had
set on the sixth day,
I was aware of every
sound, every movement.
I felt a lightness,
a vitality, as
though I could race
straight uphill
without my heart rate rising.
I saw myself again as a warrior.
On our sixth night, our
captors hatched a plan.
They, too, were
starving and cold.
So Abdul would return
to our base camp
to scavenge any remaining
food and warmer clothes.
The rest of us would ascend
a 2,000 foot mountain side--
a mixture of callous fields and
nearly vertical cliff bands.
To us, at least in our normal
states, it was easy terrain.
Abdul, after gathering
more rations,
would come up another side,
a less treacherous way,
and meet us on top.
For the first time,
we were alone with Su.
The moon plays tricks in the
darkness, casting shadows
that dance across the cliffs.
A jumbled mess of stone
disappears below--
blackness.
Far in the distance, stars
illuminate the jagged spires
and snow covered mountains.
Su's feet skid as he
lets out a pain grunt.
I watch as Singer
guides him, pointing out
footholds and hand-holds
solid enough to grab.
The plan had been for Beth
and me to stay above, out
of the fall line.
We climb higher.
Su wobbles again and I
hear the clatter of rocks
tumbling down the
nearly sheer drop off.
Now.
Silently, I'm urging
them to do it--
willing them to do it.
Singer and Dickey
resume their guiding.
More spots pass where Su
is exposed and insecure.
I try not to think about what
it is that I wish-- that I'm
wishing that they would do.
As the top nears, Su gains
confidence and scrambles ahead
of them, using his hands
to keep his balance
as he clambers over loose rock.
At a more difficult section,
just 50 feet from the top,
but 20 feet to our
right, he slows.
Singer and Dickey
are still below.
I glance down.
Our eyes meet.
They nod.
I look at Beth.
I'm going to have to
do this, I whisper.
It has to be me.
She trembles.
Shadows cross her face.
Her lips opened slightly,
but no sounds escape.
For a moment, we
stare at one another.
She dips her head--
I know.
The strength has been growing
into a monster inside of me,
emerging from nowhere,
from everywhere,
unlike anything I've known.
I accelerate across
a series of footholds
with the swiftness
of a mountain goat,
staying silent
through the shadows.
15-- 10-- five feet
away and still,
Su doesn't see me coming.
The barrel of his rifle
glistens under the stars.
I see the outline
of the grotesque
mole on his upper lip.
My foot dislodges a
loose chunk of rock.
He turns sharply towards me.
Our eyes lock.
I lunge for the strap of the
gun slung over his shoulder.
I pull as hard as I can
and push his shoulder.
His body arcs backwards
through the blackness, outlined
by the moon.
He cries out in
surprise and fear.
His body lands on a
ledge with a sickening
thud and then bounces
towards oblivion.
For a moment, I hear
and feel nothing.
Then, vertigo strikes me.
I think the sun is rising.
Glimmers of light blur into
long, indistinct streaks,
somehow real and surreal
at the same time.
Suddenly, as if a stone has
crashed down on my head,
every muscle in my
body contracts and I
squeeze my eyes shut
as hard as I can.
I scramble and sprint
the remaining distance
to the top of the mountain,
where I stand alone, panting.
I drop to the ground
and tuck myself
into as tight of a
ball as possible.
I rock back and forth, sobbing.
Everything I've held
inside floods out of me.
I just killed a man.
Not an evil villain, but a man
not so different from myself--
scared, juvenile, a man
who probably had a family
at home waiting for his return.
I shouted at God to wake
me from this nightmare.
It was too horrible to be real.
I shook uncontrollably and
wondered if I was going mad."
So yeah, writing those
first words in this book
was like this incredibly
cathartic experience.
Not only was it kind of
traumatizing, in a way,
because I can suddenly
like feel that fear again
and smell the
smells, but it also
started to help me knit together
these kind of crazy experiences
I had.
And when I thought
about writing a book,
I kind of thought I was going
to write a typical adventure
story, something
relatively uplifting.
And then I wrote these
scenes, and I was like--
whoa, this is heavy.
Like, the heaviness of my
life kind of struck me.
And so I think this book has
a lot of heaviness in it.
And so I felt like,
after writing that,
like I needed to
finish this book.
Before, I knew I
wanted to write a book.
Afterwards, I just
knew that there
was no option but to actually
continue writing this thing
and see it through.
And I became very,
very obsessed by it,
by the same way
that I do climbing.
So Kelly and I
really-- we sat down
and we started to kind of
dissect my life a little bit.
We wanted to bring out some of
the essence of what climbing
is, of what my story is,
which, in a lot of ways,
it's of overcoming
adversities-- taking
these hard experiences in life
and figuring out-- figuring out
how to have them energize you,
and turn them into something
good.
And as I started back at the
beginning, in my childhood,
I realized that everything
was so intertwined.
When I wrote that
Kyrgyzstan section,
I think I did it then because
I felt like it was somehow
related to the Dawn Wall.
But when I started at the
beginning, I was like--
it's all intertwined.
And so I started to
think about things like--
a big emerging thing was
this father-son relationship.
What does it mean to have this
father that is so full of life
that he's able to make
his body look like this?
Kind of a crazy dude--
and then what's the
psychological effect, if as
a kid, if all you want to do is
to make yourself look like him?
Yeah.
I really love the part
of this book that really
deals with that relationship.
I think I realized
how powerful that is.
And especially as
a dad these days,
I wanted to kind of analyze
how my dad had raised me,
just to see how I would
do things differently.
And then another big theme
is the power of nature.
I mean, my dad had me
out in the mountains
from a really young age.
He loves tell the story
about me taking me
into a raging blizzard
when I was three years old,
and digging a snow
cave, and having
us sleep in the snow cave, where
he said he actually changed
my diapers, in a snow
cave, in a blizzard, when
I was three years old.
And we did things like
this all the time.
Like, I-- there was--
I have countless
memories of like running
from lightning storms.
By the time I was six, I
knew like when lightning
is close by, you need to like
crouch in this certain position
so that the electricity won't
travel through you if you
get struck by lightning.
And I learned to really
love this environment, but I
also, possibly, like the--
like what risk is might
have got a little bit
tweaked in my head.
Like I became--
I became almost addicted
to these experiences,
in this weird way.
And so a lot of this
book deals with risk.
This is an interesting
quote that I came across
when I was writing this book.
This is from a friend of
mine, actually, Tom Hornbein,
who wrote a really, really
beautiful book called "the West
Ridge of Everest".
He was on the team that did
the first ascent of that route
on Everest, way back when you
had to hike 200 miles even
just to get to the
base of the mountain.
But he's a doctor,
and so the quote is,
"maybe we can view risk
like we would a drug--
beneficial to the organism
in its proper dose--
too much or too little
may be harmful".
So the middle part of
this book is really
just story after story of me
going out in the mountains
and pushing myself, sometimes
to pretty extreme places,
and I wondered why I did this.
Here's another passage
from the middle
that I'm going to read you.
This is my first
trip to Patagonia
in southern Argentina.
"The days passed and we
couldn't push any higher.
Nearly 2,000 feet up the wall,
we came upon a small perch--
perch atop a detached flake,
some 16 inches off the rock
face and three feet wide.
The snow and ice caked
itself in the narrow gap.
This would have to be our bivy.
We packed more snow
to level the surface.
Backs to the wall and sitting
upright, feet and legs
stuffed into a light
person, two person--
lightweight, two-person bivy
sack with no sleeping bag,
we tried to rest.
I ran slings around
my upper body
to latch myself to the rock.
I clipped my helmet strap to
the lines to support my head.
I was like an insect
caught in a spider's web.
Dust spilled spectral
red, yellow, blue, indigo,
and violet, all stacked
and blended together
across the western sky.
The wind had exhausted
itself and lain down.
All was still.
All was real and
utterly beautiful.
Only when I closed my eyes and
the natural wonders went dark,
did a lance of cold
and fear pierce me.
Teeth chattering,
flesh stinging cold
had me rattling against
my web of slings
like a shivering puppet.
Why the hell would anybody
put himself through this?
I beat my heels up
and down, trying
to stir blood flow
into my wooden feet.
The cold had seeped
into my brain
and I kept thinking
that I was going
to lose my toes and fingers.
I thought of Beth, and lying
nestled against her body
radiating heat.
I had visions of the
black and withered toes
of friends of frostbite
victims that I had seen.
Finally, first light crept in.
As high as we were, on the
highest mountain in the range,
we stared at the sliver of
sun, awaiting its warmth,
grateful that we were now
in some kind of purgatory--
not quite heaven, but
no longer frozen hell.
I began untangling myself
from the web of slings.
We rose and continued
climbing, but our pace slowed.
Seeps of meltwater leftover
from the last storm
had frozen, leaving the face
coated in a treacherous veneer
of verglas.
Clouds built overhead.
We could hear the wind
coming from the west
like an enraged beast.
Though Topher and I were
protected on the east face,
I could see massive chunks
of ice flying from the summit
and landing a mile
away on the glacier.
I was strangely at peace
as the mountain came alive
and the sky turned dark.
We were some 2,500
feet above the glacier
when we began a hasty retreat.
The storm blasted in
with alarming suddenness,
growing as we descended,
leaving us soaked and shivering.
We stumbled down the glacier
protected by Fitz Roy's hulking
mass.
When we emerged from
the sheltered side,
the wind threw me to the ground.
I knelt on the glacier,
anchored by my ice tool,
and I tucked my head to avoid
the flying shards of ice.
Soon after, I lost
hold of my helmet
and watched it blow into
the sky over the horizon.
Despite the storm's flurry,
soon the wind calmed
and the skies cleared.
Different sounds then emerged--
the rumble of collapsing
seracs, the crunch
of crampons in the snow,
the rhythm of our breaths.
Rocky summits glowed
crystal clear.
There was beauty as peaceful
as anything I had known."
So a lot of this
was really trying
to digest these
experiences, and trying
to figure out why I
feel almost moved,
or the need to push
myself to these extremes.
And I wrote this at a time in
my life, which was actually
really good because I was trying
to figure out not only how
to be a good husband
to my wife, but also
be a good dad to my kids.
[LAUGHTER]
TOMMY CALDWELL: Everybody
loves that photo.
The last excerpt that
I'm going to read,
here, is a letter that
I wrote to my son, Fitz,
after another trip to Patagonia.
This was my fourth trip to
this same mountain range.
And this is kind of
where my thoughts went
after I was a new dad, and I
actually went on this trip.
This was the first time I
went to a big mountain region
and brought my family with me.
They were staying
in town at the base
of the mountains for the
majority of this trip,
while I won't go into
the mountains and climb.
So this is the letter--
"it's hard to believe
that just one week ago, I
said goodbye to you and your
mom as you boarded the bus
to start your travels home,
and I hiked into the mountains.
So much has happened since
then and I'm struggling
to wrap my head around it.
I've had a huge
adventure, for sure.
I wonder if you
would have recognized
Alex and me staggering back into
El Chalten, with ripped clothes
and the fuzzy remains of our
rope draped over my shoulder.
Alex had to walk close behind
me because he was snow blind.
We looked and smelled awful.
When we got to town,
we heard the news
that Chad Kellogg was dead--
killed by rockfall
two days earlier.
Do you remember him smiling--
smiling at you from the end
of the table at [INAUDIBLE]??
He was a new friend, as
experienced a climber
as any of us.
The news made me nauseous
and took my breath away.
I choose to climb where
the risks are manageable
and tell myself that
experience will keep me safe,
but this could have happened
to anyone on the mountain.
I think of you and your mom--
she knew who she was
marrying, but you
had no choice in the matter.
I contemplate the
last five days,
the more than 12,000 vertical
feet of climbing, and 100 or so
repels we just did--
was it real?
I feel inspired in a way that
only love and a grand journey
can bring about.
While you and your mom
were cozy back in Colorado,
I was in the middle
of a struggle.
My partner, Alex, and I had
dreamed, like so many others,
of traversing the
entire Fitz Roy range.
It was an obvious goal,
but I didn't really
believe we would succeed.
No one had, yet.
It was just too big.
And yet, here we were,
a third of the way
through the traverse,
and high on Cerro Fitz
Roy-- the mountain
you're named after."
I omitted the middle
of the letter but--
"sitting safely now,
in central El Pino,
I ink my journal with
more ramblings of life,
love, the pursuit of a dream--
pondering the merit of
mountain climbing now
that I am a father.
Risk is selfish.
The biggest tragedy
I can imagine
is not being there to see
you take your first steps,
fall in love for the
first time, or come
to realize that you're
blessed with the most
beautiful, joyful, and
graceful mom in the world.
But for me, climbing makes
everything else fit into place.
It's what lights the
fire, makes me a dreamer.
The need to battle is built
into the fabric of who we are.
As humans, we may fight
with the ones we love,
poison our bodies
with drugs, go to war.
For many, the struggle
is a desperate attempt
to fill a void, but I find
my battle on the mountain,
despite the risk and
fear that resides there.
It breathes life into me.
If I can show you
one thing, I hope
it will be choose your own--
chosen struggle, wherever
you may find it, with vigor,
optimism, and love.
I love you, Daddy."
So yeah, the middle of
this book gets a bit heavy,
but there is a happy
ending, I will say.
And it really comes
down to me figuring out
that the answer is really
finding this balance--
finding the climbs
and the experiences
in life that fulfill me, that
bring me into the mountains,
that challenge me, but
that I'm relatively
certain I'll live through.
And so that was the Dawn Wall.
That's one of the reasons I
got so obsessed by this thing.
I could bring my
family to Yosemite.
I would go up on the wall,
and I never feared death,
but I was totally lit
up by the journey.
Instead of going into
the Dawn Wall thing,
I'm going to show you
guys a little trailer.
This is-- I hesitated a
little bit showing this to you
today because it's
a bit complicated,
but the filmmaker,
Josh Lowell, he
was along with us on the
journey for seven years,
and he's been working very
hard to make this film.
He didn't have the time
to make a trailer for me
to show at these events.
They had sold the distribution
rights of this film
to Red Bull Media House.
And so Red Bull Media House
put together this trailer.
It's a little bit cheesy.
[LAUGHTER]
If you like Disney movies,
you'll probably love it.
But yeah, so anyways-- this
is actually kind of a preview,
in a way, to a film that
will probably out this fall.
Maybe this fall-- we'll
see when it comes out.
But just remember-- put
your cheese goggles on
and, yeah-- enjoy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PHONE RINGING]
- Hello?
- Hey guys, it's John Branch
from "The New York Times."
How's it going up there?
- On the air tonight
with a story of two
men attempting to free climb
the famously steep face
of El Capitan in Yosemite.
- Tommy Caldwell and Kevin
Jorgenson attempt the hardest
free-climb in the world--
- --using only their finger
tips to grasp razor sharp edges.
- It's been six
years in the making--
3,000 feet of
straight up granite.
- I mean, it just
looked impossible.
- This is just a
monumental project.
- There's a lot in Tommy's
past that prepared him
for this incredible challenge.
- For Tommy Caldwell, this is
not his most miraculous story
of survival.
- He was taken hostage.
- We wake up into gunshots.
- Tommy was using his
parents old table saw.
- He did something that
he should never do.
- When I heard he'd cut
his finger off-- you now,
so much for Tommy Caldwell.
- He cuts off his finger and
then he comes back way better.
- He overcame all
of these challenges
and it just made him
even more determined.
- Seeing footage of Tommy trying
to free-climb the Dawn Wall,
trying to do these crazy moves--
I just sent him a
Facebook message-- hey,
do you need a partner?
And here we go.
- This might be the last time we
walk for a couple weeks, dude.
- Yeah.
- That way is made up
of thousands of little
micro-sequences that have
to be done perfectly.
- Everything was going
smoothly until Jorgenson
couldn't grasp pitch 15.
- Jorgenson was stopped by the
sheer difficulty of the climb.
- Going to the top
of without Kevin
was going to be devastating.
- What are you thinking?
- Everything I can to help him.
- We were in this
thing together.
- I just had to give
it one more try.
- I decided in that moment that
we were going get to the top
together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This is the best climbing
story of our generation.
- You have these moments
where you have an opportunity
to be a part of this
piece of history.
- Winds 30 to 50 miles per hour.
I love that.
- Woo!
- Yeah!
[CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
TOMMY CALDWELL: Cool.
Yeah, that's what I
got for you guys today.
Is there any questions?
AUDIENCE: In the film with you
and Alex climbing Fitz Roy,
you mentioned that
you had taken risks
that you felt were inappropriate
because you had just
become a father--
would you-- do you
still believe that?
Or would you like to
elaborate on that?
TOMMY CALDWELL: Yeah, I mean,
it's-- for me, I think--
for me, I think the way that
I was raised, like I said,
it maybe altered risk in
my mind, just a little bit.
And so when I'm up on the
mountain and scary things
happen--
usually, my go-to, like my
reaction at the time is to be
like--
it's probably not
going to happen again.
Like, a giant rock falls
off the mountain and lands
20 feet from us, and makes
this big boom, and I'm like--
that's probably not
going to happen again.
And I understand, in a way,
that that's not totally right.
Like, that's not normal.
And so I have to be
cautious from afar.
Alex Honnold is like my
drug dealer, in a way,
he's my pusher.
He's like-- it's going to be
so good, if you get us up there
and simul climb.
It's true-- it is
like addicting.
And I get pulled into
that world, occasionally,
but hopefully I'll
find that balance.
It's really part of
what writing this book
is because I hope it'll
hit home, you know.
Cool.
Yup.
Right there.
AUDIENCE: You worked
for years on Dawn Wall,
and you finally succeeded--
congrats on that, of course.
TOMMY CALDWELL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: But then
Ondra repeated
relatively soon afterwards--
what was your take on that?
TOMMY CALDWELL: Yeah, so--
yeah, for those of you who
don't know, there was this--
there was this Czech phenom
climber, Adam Ondra, who came,
I guess, about a year or two
years after I finished the Dawn
Wall, and basically did in a
month what it took me seven
years to do, which was--
honestly, I wish it would have
taken him like a year, maybe.
But it was hugely inspiring.
And I think-- he trains
like an Olympian.
He's like-- he's got so much
fire, and he's very scientific.
And it's like a testament
to where this world can go.
I think, in terms of
difficulty of rock climbing,
there's a vast world.
We only understand
this much about it.
And I'm going to be
the hugest fan of what
happens in the future, forever.
I'm definitely going to be one
of those old men in the coffee
shop just talking
about the climbing,
constantly, because it's so
fun to see that stuff go down.
Cool.
Well, yeah, we'll be hanging
out for a little bit,
but thank you, Sandy and Brady.
SANDY: [INAUDIBLE]
TOMMY CALDWELL: Yeah, go ahead.
No, I'm good.
I'm done, thank you.
SANDY: Thanks.
Well, I just wanted
to say, like, one,
thank you for coming.
Thank you to Brady.
They're both very nice, but it's
a massive team of people that's
been helping both Tommy, Alex,
Sundar, and the Access Fund,
and it's just--
I mean, that's the
mating part about Google,
is that if you have an idea,
you can really push it.
So if you are excited
about something,
if you want to do something
with them, if you have ideas--
please come talk to me,
definitely reach out to Brady.
And huge thanks also,
Wayne, is in the back--
his whole team were really
instrumental in the Street
View, and getting Earth
imagery of Yosemite,
that made the project possible.
So thank you.
TOMMY CALDWELL: Oh yeah, and
maybe I'll just add to that.
It's funny-- when I
was up on the Dawn Wall
and this whole media
thing was going down,
the Street View team was
kind of like assembling,
and it just happened to
be the same filmmakers
that I was up there with.
And so on our rest days, we were
like bringing GoPro's up there,
and building these bundles,
and taking everything
out testing them up on the wall.
And this world of--
trying to figure out
ways to tell these stories
and bring them to the world
has become a really fun
thing, and yeah, Google's
been part of that.
And so I came down
from the Dawn Wall.
I went on the Ellen
DeGeneres show.
I went to LA for
a few days, then
I came right back to
Yosemite and went back up
on El Cap to film that
Street View thing that Sandy
showed in the beginning.
So yeah, like she said, if
there's-- if there's any way
to integrate climbing
into this Google world,
it's fun for climbers
to do that so.
[APPLAUSE]
TOMMY CALDWELL: Awesome.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.